[Music]
austin is in springfield missouri to
start off this particular hour hey
austin what's up
hello dave nice to talk to you you too
how can we help
my question is i'm 22 years old and i'm
wanting to start investing
and i'm wanting to know
which platform i should use
wise man all right so you're out of
college you're working
i did not go to college i'm working i
actually own a construction and
excavating business of my own way to go
man that's incredible okay so what's
your income for the year household
income
my income is around 45 000 a year
cool
and i i do own my house it's completely
paid off wow
what's that worth
my home appraised around 220 000
way to go man well you're doing great
already right off the bat you're killing
it do you have any debt
no i know credit card debt or student
loans nothing and you have an emergency
fund you have savings three to six
months expenses yes
yes my emergency fund is around 25 000.
would you run for congress
22 years old you have your crap together
more than any of them at the island of
misfit toys
i i wish but um very um
i got a lot of my information from you
dave obviously and plus my family and my
parents they blessed
me with a lot of knowledge and stuff but
no handouts but a lot of knowledge and
i'm very grateful for that yeah they
raised a great kid man well let's talk
about the investing side now have you
invested at all in anything so far or is
this all new no sir i have not um
started investing at all um
in any type of cryptocurrency or
anything
all right well here's what i would do if
i were if i were you in your shoes i
would be investing 15 of my income into
retirement accounts so things like a
401k if you have access to that i know
you've got your own business but you
don't so maybe a solo 401k or a sep ira
for you
but iras and those kinds of retirement
accounts is where i'd be putting that 15
and you can you can put a lot of money
in there if you're self-employed yeah
you can put six thousand dollars into
just a simple roth ira
that's a very easy transaction and that
would that would be pretty close to your
15 at this stage of the game so what you
do just click on at ramseysolutions.com
just click on smart vester pro sit down
with one of the people that we endorse
for investing we call them smart vester
pros you're the smart investor they're
the pro that helps you do it
you're a smart investor and you are you
are you qualify dude well done but they
can set that up and you can have it come
out directly out of your checking
account monthly if you want to break it
down monthly be 500 bucks a month if you
want to uh do it one time in a lump sum
you can do that
i'd recommend just setting up a monthly
draft
because i like getting smart things on
autopilot
so i never have to think about them
again so i'm automatically smart i like
that i like that you can automate
smartness that's a i don't know
smartness not a word i'm not there yet
well i'll get there smartness smart
whatever it is that's whatever whatever
it is it follows that wisdom we're going
to just put it on autopilot and where we
automatically are smart and i i just
i've always try to do that trick myself
into doing smart things and you learn to
live on whatever's left and then you're
really winning exactly well done austin